Music Playing
Dear diary,
Today I start you, my video diary,
because well in a nutshell,
everything in my life is changing.
I’m Bonnie Hunt, writer, director and executive producer of the new Apple TV Plus series, Amber Brown.
Oh yeah.
Very cool!
I’m Sarah Drew and I play Amber’s mom.
Who just so happens to also be called Sarah.
Amber is a girl who is just starting middle school and going through a lot of changes.
So she uses her video diary and sketching to kind of help her through that.
I love that you're doing your art, but you know, you also need people,
Friends are good to have.
Hi! I’m Brandi with an ‘I’.
I like to think about it as kind of like the yin and yang symbol.
Amber is very introverted and Brandi is an extrovert.
Sometimes I think I like to be one of them for a day, but then I'd miss myself.
They're so different, but they really balance each other out.
You're unusual.
Thank you.
Now that’s a compliment.
The show is inspired by the books entitled Amber Brown, written by Paula Danziger, and woven into the childhood of many girls and boys.
My best friend Justin is moving to Alabama. And my mom’s got a boyfriend. It’s weird.
We walk through every single thing that this sweet little girl is going through by getting a window into her life, through video diaries.
And through her sketches,
Earlier today, I walked smack into a pillar right in front of the cutest boy in the whole school.
Oh!
Some of those come to life in full animation.
It’s kind of a way for the audience to not only hear what Amber says in front of everybody, but to see what she’s feeling in her deepest inner thoughts.
I'm cool.
What I saw in the script, the characters were really beautifully developed.
It was funny.
It was innovative in the way that we get inside of the mind of this eleven year old who’s going through huge changes in her life.
Do you wanna sit together? For lunch?
Yeah.
The show is from Amber's point of view, but it really is about all families and a lot of kids at this age,
you know, that pre teenage years, life can feel overwhelming at times and complicated.
There's my girl!
We get a window into the beauty of how family can take lots of different shapes.
This is so exciting.
You could be going through the most intense problem ever, and you could just crack up right in the middle of it.
All the things that Amber goes through real people go through which can really help you feel like you’re not alone.
This is the best day ever!
I’ll never forget this.
♪♪